there are no poor people in Cambridge
anymore they're pretty much all gone and
those were my customers too they they
needed paper and they needed pens and I
had lots of poets and they had to move
out of the city they're just no place
for them to live now it Cambridge is
beautiful now compared to what it was
let's be honest Central Square was it
had in many instances few years ago was
pretty dumb p and now it's cleaned
itself up and it's looking pretty good
same Kendall Square was a mess there was
nothing in Kendall Square and God knows
it it's really looking terrific and even
the Department of Transportation is
going to redo its facility and I'm sure
that mit has a lot to do with that so it
has a lot of plusses and then the river
is beautiful but the poor people and the
working class people they cannot live on
the apartments by the river and that's
that that said because you got a whole
generations of families when history of
in Cambridge and they they they had to
move out I mean one of the things that
one of the last things I did as mayor
was to write a letter to the president
of MIT and say we really need
internships for our kids we need our
kids to have time times places where
they can work in the summer time where
they can experience science directly and
and president rife was very welcoming
and and said that that was a good idea
of the challenges that are out there for
outside with science education are
tremendous you know with in so many ways
but for us in Cambridge where all the
jobs so many of the great jobs are in
Kendall Square and in science and
technology and engineering arts and math
steam
we really have to work together to make
sure that kids have a ladder a row a
roadmap whatever analogy you want to use
a metaphor for them to be able to feel
very empowered over being able to get
jobs and those really important how
feels I think this has been a terrific
terrific relationship over the past
hundred years and and you know I might
have experienced around 20 or 25 of the
shi'ites but I think that that the
institute has been there for Cambridge I
think that obviously the impact on our
economy I think on jobs in this
community on education I think those are
all very very positive things for this
community and and you know I think we
have a lot more things that we can
collectively address and and you know i
look forward to how we can figure out to
work together on issues affecting our
young people in sparking the interest in
science and technology in and making
kids dream and making kids think about
all the opportunities that are available
to them and i think we can do that
together